[Music] citizens of the reject Nation I
have an important question for you would
you rather be a troll or would you rather
band together because you can't do both
except we're here today for trolls B together
don't ha me I was haing in conjunction with
you was a yes and also what's your hul
uh I what was your H I was trying to
yes s and it I want to hear it again I I
want to do it again no I want to hear it
again coming from Miss raspy over here Mak for
I you're right I have no right to make fun of
anybody's voice ever Greg what's up how are you
we've watched two of these trolls we're on the
third one it's been popular it's been requested
you feeling good about this I'm feeling good
about it I I Don't Know Jack about it I'm
assuming band together what a great title I
just put it together band like a band and the
baning to dual meaning oh that's great that's
clever that's some good marketing I did a whole
intro about the band together yeah but I didn't
dawn on me until like oh you're a [Music] band
uhhuh like comment subscribe let us know what
you guys thought about the first two is this the
best one so far have we heard good things uh I
don't know I haven't looked anything up I didn't
either I heard nyn does music for this oh yeah
that's the one thing we saw them do that they
did like a hot one thing or something for this
okay that's pretty cool thank you to prepper
for helping us edit down these videos if you
want to be the sexiest of Rejects and go over to
patreon where you can sync up with your own copy
over there Greg and John cover several shows
exclusively with highlights of wogs she almost
did a whole one by herself she panicked she
looked down she panicked yeah but that's okay
cuz we're going to band together now yes we are to
watch this movie before we do that do you want to
troll me for a second uh well it's a free pass to
troll uh in three two one pass over we're watching
it hit us with them
Tunes a long time ago in a troll land far far away
we're going to open with girl baby baby and close
with baby baby girl wait no that doesn't sound
right it's fine open with baby baby girl close
with baby baby girl woman okay we are going to
make boy band history tonight 51 oh how many
n sing songs do you those abs need to be popping
baby baby baby girl woman do I really have to keep
wearing these things you do Clay they're Thunder
drawers it's underwear but 76% more fun now let's
see those dance moves brother Rusty robot into bro
you look stress it's the first show of the tour we
have to to hit the perfect family harmonies
calm down you're making baby Branch nervous
baby branch no no he's not allowed to be nervous
he's got to be perfect I like how they call him
baby Branch hey Branch how you feeling I feel like
I'm going to barve a pass out and pee your pants
all at once how' you know you got the pre-show
Jitters completely normal you want to know what
I do when I get them bar pass out and PE pants yep
I remember that I'm with my brothers and that when
we come together there is nothing that we can't
do wow you band together no one's ever hit the
perfect family Harmony before is it true it can
shatter diamonds perfect family Harmony we got our
setup follow my lead or maybe let's just go out
there and have fun together so much pressure is
this end sync that's what I'm thinking must be if
we can't hit the perfect family Harmony we aren't
perfect and if we aren't perfect we're nothing
follow my lead and the harmony will happen I don't
know what any of their voices sound like I I do
but I it's really hard to tell here spru sensitive
one it's been a while since I've seen a boy
bad parody but it also feels like an [Music]
homage oh this is
cool I'm digging this song yeah me too
they just did that that in sync move
so who's that maybe it's Justin
Tiber like with Voice [Music]
modulated Greg I don't want to put you on the spot
but name one member of ins synct
that isn't JT Lance B this isn't
myo to the perfect [Music] harmony oh guys
[Music]
guys who would be fun kind of though if it wasn't
so scary see what happens when you don't follow
my lead dude that is exactly what happens when
we follow your lead I wonder if this is a play
on real life no then they'd be fighting with JT
dude this used to be fun now it's all about being
perfect you know what I'm done playing the heart
drop I quit I quit too I've had that conversation
before I'm going to find trolls who take me
seriously fine I don't need this I'm out guys I'm
going to go hike the neverglade trail by myself
bro loan yeah that's right bro bro going solo YOLO
have a lot of these interesting like one shot they
move like a music video like a K-pop video it's my
fault so is that one lance we're not in sync we're
not in sync Boys to Men and now there's only one
direction for us to go the back street back street
the earring is on his right ear which is what you
do to when you're queer and get one piercing it's
time to start a solo career what am I going to do
you are going to do the most important thing of
all you're going to take care of grandma this guy
BR has had so much Dr tra when you miss me you can
wear this it'll be like I'm right here with you
and when you come back we'll make our Hideout wow
is that a 10 Story water slide yeah that's how we
shower we always thought this was Poppy's
Trilogy it's branches I'll see you soon baby
Branch BBB baby Branch what's up baby I think
it is they talked about solo careers name drop
Back Street Boys in sync Boys to Men One
Direction I think this is a play on real
life in some way yeah but he wasn't the baby
of the I think he wanted to break away right
so it's a little different but yes when
art imitates life imitating art imitating
life sup poppy are you all right you're smiling
and crying at the same time it kind of looks like
it's hurting your face no I guess I'm just missing
my um Grandma I was just listening to some of her
old records why are you missing them now no way I
love R oh my God she doesn't know it's him I mean
kind of seems like there's something you're not
telling me yep what a woman always knows if you're
having feelings you can talk about them with
I love her oh hey look at the time we're going
to be late to the Royal Wedding you don't have a
watch let's go get married Branch I I mean Bridget
and Crystal Mary please explain all men right now
what do you mean oh look at the time yeah we avoid
and we throw ourselves into work just wanted you
to say it oh yeah you know the number one cause
of depression is Nostalgia it can't be true com
don't stop it now don't stop it now don't stop
it now no a longing for the past is a leading
cause that's what you mean okay hey look at the
colors I love how this introduces kids of this
generation to such great music and this is the
version they will listen to yeah but I don't
care at least they'll know it no lie all people
she's like okay you can avoid this for now babe
not later I'll give you an hour we got to see
these guys from the kingdom from the first
movie this is a Trilogy coming full circle
we boy that was a crazy B forie Cloud guy don't
feel so good Cloud gu back they're all coming
back baby how you
feeling
oh my God cool mash up look at you tiny diamond
oh my God the diamond man's back I want to be
like him I'm the cutest little flower man but
tiny you're only a month old still I'm just a
little baby talking I don't know why I like him
so much Daddy I'm a man now not a little child
what do you think it's read like in the script
probably just Bonkers yeah we are is true you got
to like really visually map it out the colors are
just always so great in this I like this first 10
minutes more than the first 10 minutes of Charles
World Tour already more emotionally invested in it
well I don't know what the emotional conflict is
going to be yet like he wants to find his brothers
again um I like all the trolls movies so far and
this is an iconic outfit yes balloon Queen poppy
thank you so much for being my Made of Honor a
I love you like a sister probably I don't have
a sister so I wouldn't know which is fine it's
something I'm coming to terms with slowly uh poy
can we maybe unpack the sister thing after the
V I guess that's the bee story well maybe just
the fact that he has brothers that she doesn't
know about and she's going to be like I always
wanted a sister you have all these brothers you
don't even see M good prediction will poppy and
Branch get married in this one we are gathered
here today to celebrate the Sweet Love Falling
in Love is Easy I didn't find it easy at all
let's unpack that stop the wedding what who
dare protest is this bad timing I'm just trying to
find a troll name baby Branch uh you're making a
mistake stranger that looks similar to me there's
no Branch here you're not a branch anymore you
more like a trunk Chunk in the trunk ow whoa
inappropriate you got heavy oh my God horse oh
God twoe hes hey this is why you stopped the
wedding oh he just was coming to find his he
didn't mean to yeah you're right I'm Branch's
brother what drama cor me corn me V me leaving
the room dad did you know about this what would
I know about secret family members does she have
a secret sister what did we know about I feel
like that's a reference to something previous
brozone we were just listening to them yeah
brozone wait wait wait wait wait don't tell
me um okay well you're not the heart throb well
that's your opinion you're John Dory the leader
the old one the old one if your branch is bro
then that means that all the other bro Zone
Bros are branches Bros too you come from wealth
Branch Branch was in the band all right no way
which one was he bitty B A faletto made of gold
but that's all in the past because they stopped
being my brothers the day they walked out on
me and never came they did abandon him I did
come back but no one was there it wasn't until
I heard about you saving the world from The Rock
apocalypse that I realize you were even still
alive trolls World Tour I need something it's
about Floyd he's in Danger Man cool transition
Floyd is Lance I have no idea I got a letter
from him Dear John Dory I'm being held against
my will by Superstars velvet and veneer come
to mount raes at once and bring our brothers
the sensitive one I didn't know where any of
you were so I went to mount Rous so must be Lance
who mount rageous looks contagious looks like a
rage Fest mine was better mine was was way better
Mine rhy Mine mine's more accurate cuz it's not
contagious I found where this velvet and veneer
were performing it's good back and forth we're
having right now I am courageous made of these oh
this is a really appropriate song for children to
disagree wow look this must be one of
the most covered songs ever yeah [Music]
so they left the band to become action
heroes he's like a spy and there
was Floyd they're keeping him
hostage oh this this one isn't Lance velvet
and veneer are giant pop obsessed succubi
with no talent and they've been stealing mine
that's even worse than lips the bottle is made
of diamond and there's only one thing to
shatter Diamond his voice it's the perfect
family Harmony wow oh this is going to be a
rescue movie this is your second chance with
your brothers Branch it's not that easy okay
you don't have any siblings that's my point
Branch you are so lucky to have a brother
to fight for I mean if I had a sister it
would be so perfect you are so poppy why did
he hide the sister thing if she were ever in
trouble I would do everything I could to help
her you have an ideal fantasy of what a sister
should be like no that's me and my sister if
there was a brother that I might do this for
and I'm not saying there is it would be Floyd
I'm not hearing no you're definitely a poppy
oh I don't know we're going to find them love
her being like no here's how you should feel
and here's what you should do that's what I do
yeah I tell you how to feel you really think so
what the hell is this thing this is creepy
this is some type of monster their version
of a bus I guess she likes me yeah she does
or she's marking you as prey can never quite
tell with Rhonda Rhonda the board is going
AB board hi everybody I told you it was a
bus it a bus dang have an awesome honeymoon
thanks poy you L I'm not sure that I'll ever
have a full wedding but if I do I'm not
I don't think I'll be a bridezilla but
that would have pissed me off of course
I could have [Music] waited oh that auto
tune all right I definitely recognize her voice
definitely I love the commentary these movies
make on the music industry and genres so what
do you want to know I'm an open book wide open
who are some of your your biggest influences
honestly V's always been my inspiration oh my
gosh H I'd have to go with also me no never mind
that's you now you're trolling me how do you guys
stay the biggest Superstars Mount rages has ever
known what's your secret secret we don't have a
secret who said we have a secret it just takes
lots of hard work and loads of natural talent
look how like flexible and bendy they are is
it possible for a troll to have a sibling that
isn't a troll time for a sprit I barely have
any Talent left to give oh really you don't
want to okay that's fine we'll just kiss our
careers goodbye and focus our efforts on charity
a interesting commentary on people who feel
like hasbin and then the new electronic era of
music that's more like it they're like Ursula
yeah so is is he going to lose all his talent
or does he get to like rebuild it why do you
have resting Moody Vibe face no I know we've
deserve to be famous just cuz we want to it's all
going to change as soon as we have brozone brozone
guys these guys are frustrating I forged a letter
begging for them to come and save you no you leave
my brothers alone oh what a smart bab yeah that's
what I was thinking how did he write the letter
in the stuck inside this is for all the love l a
solo thinking us I love the music in [Music] this
ride [Music] that there is more of a Melancholy
to this one this one's made me a little sad yeah
tiny I am no longer a baby and I'm on a man-sized
r of Passage to learn lesson of life should we be
letting a baby drive baby driver I have procured
my learner permit who is a Doty mcmah fate are
you a n what no no why are you enough chitchat
adulty McMahon face step on it are you a Nar is
such a great this movie makes Justin Timberlake
look so good not forgetting about his former band
mates check out your old outfits puffy jackets
hook shell necklaces denim tuxedos Ranch did you
have frosted tips uh don't forget his perm no
wayct didn't happen you say Nostalgia leads to
depression it's it's cheering me up right now
we don't need your little board to find Spruce
I got this we can't find Spruce with this yeah we
can all we have to do is find this Sunset likeing
that optimism poppy seed Branch one word keeper oh
I think he'll marry her look at this we're never
going to find Spruce with this I bet the sunset
doesn't even exist amazing what a moment yes
Nails awesome this is the most romantic
honeymoon I've ever been on it is a night of
surprises this one is uh they they really up I
said it last movie but even this time around I
think visually there there's so much variety
here looks like clamation so um John who wrot
that song girl I love your love girl I did
cool who wrote um girl you break my heart
girl I did so cool swashbucklers branch has
never written a song I was a baby what did
you want me to write about diaper rash Yes W
this looks so fun amusement park ride right
like this would be great I don't know why
they haven't tried doing it yet welcome to
V Island where every day is a vacation so the
animation looks creepy totally you can't find
[Music]
say this genuinely looks horrifying to me
yeah this is definitely trippy the sun is so
freaky whoa It's Like Diamonds [Music] looks
like little bath bombs they make the world
feel tangible it's your brothers bitty B what the
last time I saw you you were in diapers diapers
right wet wiie Stop Wet Willie I am a grownup oh
sorry a wet William wet William we're here because
actually no one's called me Spruce in years I go
by Bruce now I wanted to put the whole boy band
thing thing behind me now that I'm a dad you
can't do that you can't do that hi honey these
are my brothers oh hello there so nice to finally
meet you she looks like big bird Daddy Daddy can
I have a cookie becoming a dad was like a like
a seismic shift in my what is happened J B me no
biting Daddy I don't see how any government stands
a chance they look like Sesame they you look like
Sesame repp yeah like yeah you do remember our
last show don't you if we practice no we'll be
able to nail it but wouldn't you need the one
in the cage too he'll Sting from inside the
cage yeah I told you Dad wasn't in a band I was
in the band you asked your mother if I was in a
band he was in a band oh my God gry it prove it
prove it Prove It Go sing with your brothers but
I'm not doing it right now just for funsies no
you're afraid that singing with your brothers
again after all these years will overwhelm you
with emotions too powerful for you to handle I
don't think you can handle it so I think you
shouldn't do it I think I can handle singing
song You're her reverse like best clever
I kind of want to dress as her for
Halloween looks so sweet come
on franch prove it oh that
[Music] unbelievable [Music]
mashups oh he's [Music] glowing you're all
I ever needed can't believe this is really
[Music] happening oh oh [__] this is
[Music] cool stay in what's your go to dance
move yeah this one yeah yeah
yeah I was saying yeah I do
[Applause] this she joined in she might not
get a sister but she will have brothers but
she does have a sister somehow we don't know
that you should leave now before you get pink
eye save yourself oh my God love you abandoned
them maybe Poppy's goingon to have to help sing
I hope so and Poppy's sister this one's like
mainly about other people outside of Poppy and
Branch you know this is how she did this
no I did that's cute yeah with her nails
dolly burned me what you said you needed
a way to make your smoothies even fruer on
stage it's a high powerered vacuum you just
pop the grape or strawberry or blueberry or
guava slice and it releases the fruit's
essence through here oh no they're going
to use it for the trolls tap this button
just delicately you know like once oh
no oh my
god oh no
you said that it was for smoothies that's
horrifying deal with me if you use too much
you'll kill him the that I tested turned into
a prune I don't want to kill the little guy
they're kind of cute when they're up and about
who are these two voices I don't know go back
to the dark place where we had nothing please
sir I want some more girl we grew up in these
suburbs our parents were dentists so she not her
singing voice but she might be Amy Schumer because
I saw her do press for this movie oh okay that's
probably right you're smarter than I thought now
I don't trust you that's maybe not a rational
response I don't um please don't put me in the
cor now come on we're about to go from stars to
Mega stars have you seen blazing s not Blazing
Saddles uh the ice skating one with will frell
chalad a knce no no the ice skating one like
the Will Arnett and Amy polar the brother I I
think my answer is yes but that's Amy Schumer
not polar yeah but they were remind me of uh
what is it called but the brother and sister
Dynamic with the Jenna Fisher one they remind
me a lot of them we're going to make it we've
been looking for Clues to find clay oh I'm sorry
the Clue board you mean my Clue board that I made
we like the Clue board now what those are just
his no Thunder [Music] drawers help us Rhonda
she's got the scent e you see that button e this
is pretty gross Oh you mean the button that's
taking every fiber of my being not depressed
yeah I see it press it oh hecky yeah that's
trippy oh [Music] yes oh my
God I love it acid psychedelic
trip this is who produced the music for this
one I feel like they got a really good producer
on this one 1970s right now at the 6070s uh
hustle design holy crap oh my God we com got
a third that was excellent that was excellent
are we sure this is where clay lives DPS is an
armadillo bus sniffing used undies so no we're
not sure Yep this is a really interesting one
because I'm very much aware of like Justin
Timberlake's creative involvement in this
one now you mean like he wanted to look good I
feel like just with the end it's like this whole
Branch storyline is completely taken over and you
could feel a lot more of these different musical
influences cool they've like really
got more horror with their animation
this time around Who Dares trespass
on me S grounds France what are you
doing listen that's a great visual we're
just here looking for our brother Clay yo
trolls oh my gosh who is this my name is Viva
it is so fantastic amazing to see other trolls
she's an isolated troll is she related a poppy so
fantas amazing is my own personal word it means um
fantastic and amazing I used to say I'm Astic but
then I was like that's not as good it's got to be
Poppy's sister any troll is welcome here with
us okay papa trolls lights on oh it's a whole
society God this is sick I love a mini
golf park fries you guys want fries I
am seeing fries Bring Out The Works
milkshakes to celebrate yo this troll
is hot know what I mean you don't see
and go like it's a good looking troll
I do like her hair these fries are
amazing they' really go great with a
burger what uh veeg vegetarians it's just that
burger sounds a little too much like uh Perkins
oh oh we call Burgers meat Circle clay hey
what's up man how you man clay John why do
they all hate him well he seems to be the most
naive to how everyone else feels wait where's
Floyd Floyd's been taken prisoner in Mount
ragis by Superstar singers velvet and veneer
and the only thing powerful enough to free is the
perfect family Harmony they're slowly becoming in
harmony Lloyd is being held in an impenetrable
Diamond prison yeah that I'm in oh my God great
but we need to leave from outrageous like now
so siblings in this universe our same skin tone
yeah with po usually how it goes where' you
get that hug time bracelet my dad gave it to
me this is so totally random but I used to have
one just like it can I see that o it's going to
happen whoa what did you say your
name was again I'm poppy I'm py
poy is your dad King pee uh yeah
you're you're you're alive you're alive poppy
it's me Viva I'm your sister my my what your
sister your don't woe like you didn't know clearly
it was her sister yeah I know I'm just saying like
I'm feeling what she's feeling I've always dreamt
of having a sister I was just saying this wasn't
I just saying this this means we can complain
each other's birthday parties yeah yeah yeah
and weddings yes my best friend Bridget just
had her wedding it's turn out exactly how she
wanted it to you going to love each other oh
my gosh I'm going to love her I love what you
love is is exactly how she hoped it
would be right now but what happened
that she thought she was dead and like
does she think that the dad I don't
know I definitely recognize her voice too my
brain I've just been so dazzled by the
animation this time I'm like really sucked
[Music]
in it's weird that both Poppy and Branch just
is about their siblings at the same time kind
of interesting like almost feel like too big
of a coincidence it's a kids movie I guess
so
okay so she's a pop star of the genz Gen I
just love the heart of this one a lot I used
to live at the troll tree I was there when you
were born why am I only learning about you now
what happened we got accidentally separated and
I've lived you ever since the end she abandoned
them doesn't like to talk about it but she's
been here ever since the night of the great
Bergen attack oh this is all tying back to
the first movie not everyone made it out of
that tree they were this close to getting eaten
until Viva and some of the other trolls fought
them off but by then the tunnels had collapsed
the dad never looked for them I kept screaming
no troll left behind but when I went back in
the tunnels had collapsed that's when I found
viva's hug time bracelet a via found this old
abandoned Bergen golf course and transformed it
into this troll Utopia trop I've thought so many
times about leaving you know to look for you and
Dad but it's not safe out there she has such
an adventurous Spirit though I feel so guilty
what do you think I should do I'm afraid that's
our time for today but I just revealed a major
trauma therapists be keeping a tight 50 they
do it's like they have boundaries with their
patience and neither are you silly you're
never going to leave again what uh uh wait
what was the what was that last thing oh
my God is she a villain I'll go get Poppy
there's no way Bea's going to let her go what
are you talking about like I said just's got
some stuff going on man if we don't want to get
trapped out now if we don't want to get trapped
holy crap oh my God this is becoming fullon
horror movie now not leaving here no matter
what because because it's just not safe out
there you're welcome wait is this about the
burkins Mommy Dearest that's all in the past
yeah right that's hilarious poppy I'm laughing
really hard I'm serious she's so traumatized
Bridget and I do a million fun things together
we talk and we play games and we sing songs and
up these really bad dances my God I just got my
sister back I'm not going to lose you but you
can't helicopter parent the situation you know
selfish oh no sorry Viva but we have to leave I
don't want to lose my brother either no no puppy
wait aw I want you to stay I can't do
that but you can come with us I I know
you think it's risky and maybe
it is but it'll be worth it a I
can't sad going have to come back for
her maybe that's not what you you would
want to leave for her yeah just feel like
that would just like leave the bracelet don't
don't leave this book of my other sister who's
the Bergen the Bergen Terri I want to be famous
but I'm not going to work for it e this is like
so many Tik tokers I see remember twist our
dances sucked how many fans do you think we
can get making up sucky dances they are taking
so many Jabs at people with these two he's dead
oh man what are we doing done what do we do you
remember the Goldfish you had as a kid you mean
Sparkles being this close to
you next to a toilet makes me
uncomfortable help me please oh my God
please veneer just let me run past you
you can pretend you never saw me just because
she's your sister doesn't mean you should let
her treat you like garbage doesn't it no
that's a great listen it's a great doesn't
it sibling or not you deserve to be treated
with kindness and to be around people who
would never try to change the you that you are
I really needed this movie right now we really
make a great team don't we bro oh no now come
on they better get there soon I don't know how
people feel but I personally like this more
than the last movie really I like the story
more but it's also speaking to me in a more
personal way the limit the Stars it's it it
Blow love how he's got the diaper back
on stop stop time out let's do it again from the
top Spruce I want some smolder in those eyes this
is why people don't like him we're starting to
learn if this diaper was any smaller I could
taste it oh my God you love bossing us around
just admit it think I moved to the middle of
nowhere so I didn't have to be in charge
of anyone four little brothers is a lot
of responsibility we can't forget about Floyd
we're here for Floyd let's just get this done
and we can go our separate ways why does he
have to wear the diaper you didn't think we'd
all live together when this was all over did
you roasting marshmallows oh I'm sorry is that
funny to you that I might want us to actually be
a family again oh that's mean oh hurts pull over
now don't be a baby branch is Justin Tim really
trying to bring back and SN I stopped being a
baby the day you guys walked out on me then
Grandma Got eaten and there was no one else
to take care of me I'm walking out on you all is
so lost right now guys this is Branch's bunker he
built this for you guys oh my God it was
there in the story all along every good
Trilogy ties back to the first movie grandma
got eeden Grandma Got eaten all know I feel
like I I get more sucked into the fun of it
and you get sucked into the drama of it I'm
coming with you why bother aren't you going to
leave me eventually anyway everyone else does
I get it man I got a abandon in issues too
I have been by your side from the moment we
met and you've been by mine let's give each
other some credit here no and I'm not going
anywhere unless it's with you to save Floyd a
that's sweet it's the most mature one of the
three wow chy are they going to merge the
plot lines yeah I don't I don't need them
to I'm totally fine with this no totally I'm
just wondering if they're going to be able
to help at all cuz that's like her chosen sister
whatever oh true French yeah they're merging but
she finds the book oh she's going to realize the
Bergens are not so bad now it's feeling like a
back to the Tim Bera [Music] movie were those golf
balls oh no oh good they're just trolls look how
cute oh no what's happening this is
really creative all the amusement
parks things that they're using to
trap them with quickest way in will
be at the roof the HVAC system o I love
how you say HVAC what that's [Laughter]
hot after that oh that is so cool very cool how
do you know which wires to cut I don't I'm just
blasting everything until something turns off
this is the third Heist thing I've seen in a
row it's so funny my next movie is a heist movie
Greg no is it always l too L St back L the he wow
you've really grown into that vest you're a man
now the only one who acknowledges somebody gets
me I told you brozone would show up my letter
works I'm a genius are you sure you're sure
about this oh my God hello Floyd Brothers it's so
good to see you oh this is so this movie is super
sad just love again we're here we're having two
different experiences you get so sucked into the
like the drama of it let's go autograph some
butts oh that's fun I'll grab my butt marker
this one does go like darker for sure and it's
it's less about like their music numbers yeah
I'm going to need a bob soon oh it looks like
you need a hug oh what if someone's ever said
that to me I'd probably just like cry right
briy loving you is the best thing that ever
happened to me um would it be weird if we
made out it would be weird if we [Laughter]
didn't is this you that's me and
my best friend she's my sister
your poppy sister that makes us best friends
too so you're really not going to eat us no but I
understand the fear if you want I can
open my mouth TR sted letting yourself
feel and breathe your way through
the anxiety it's called systematic
desensitization or or I let you go and you promise
not to eat us oh that's fine too I'm loveing so
much that was a great scene but this part makes me
sad it's like every time we go to a happy part I
know you're really getting affected by it sibling
stuff rips me to shreds how's my aura confident
yet grateful to your teachers and everyone who
got you here tonight that's what I'm going for
she's such a great gaslighter I can learn a lot
from her you know what I mean SC you want to
succeed you're stealing Bran's talent because
you have none of your own you big oh you big
phonies okay we need to leave oh here we go
chasing but what was their plan there I mean
there was a public confrontation
yeah but they didn't get back the
bros man I'm trying to get through but they got
no respect for the blinker no respect for the
blinker can you wink can you can you do both
eyes yeah good back for back back [Laughter]
[Music]
back wow this Roose look
nauseating hold her steady
tiny this one's like an action
movie get you guys out of [Music]
here this feels like Mario Kart
it really does especially that
part this was like rainbow road but Red
Road I'm gonna learn how to fly
see I can deal with my heartache
over this when we've got good music
going on oh no what do we do let's
hustle yes the best part can you please drop
us off at that boat down there AB hust not
literally woo yes we would have been here
sooner but we had to make a pickup first
awesome I'm kind of freaking out a little bit
I love this moment you've got a Really Brave
sister actually I've got two Really Brave
sisters a oh gr this so touching no gray
I love that our stories complicated who cares
if it's not perfect as long as we're together
I should have come with you I was just did
you just braid my hair yeah learn from the
best oh my gosh it is so fantastic amazing I
love visual gags like that that was so good
yeah all you want in life is people to show up
for you when you need them I will watch always
Lola that is what I was angling
at whoa shees i k you I like the scale on this a
lot let's bro
[Music] neat oh so inventive I love those but
when they get caught on your hair oh man that's
annoying you deserve a burn oh they're going
to make everybody sing for the diamonds to
break Floyd will never make it he's got
nothing left craig Greg we don't have to
be perfect to be in harmony we just have to
be as we are together oh I'm sick right now
Greg
what yay some kind of love it's of oh
here we go my whole body is [Music]
tingling oh hell yeah oh goost bumps me too
[Music] everywhere damn what a
reunion
damn who they're producing on the songs at this
time do you think everybody realizes their brozone
yeah papy just fan girl this whole [Music]
time oh the harmony
Break Free Break
Free place a perfect harmony no the talent no
no Greg no if he dies I boycott the franchise
Floyd come on man wake up no way he's dead I
built The Hideout Floyd except the Story water
slide their love will resurrect him how will
we shower no way yeah we are FRS wow and we've
been literally torturing little trolls we just
wanted to be famous honestly my sister wanted
to be famous and truly I was too afraid to
stand up to her don't don't just make her
now everyone's just going to blame her now but
also like he's saying this now too little too
late I mean Crim what are you doing I was just
saying that I had a change of heart you also
engaged in troll napping troll torture there
we go fraud fair enough prison it is w a yay
you could do a Good Morning America interview
now how you feeling happy grateful really sorry
that it's taken me this long to open up to you a
there should be dwarf um grateful okay oh she's
cute they're such a cute couple just braided your
hair it means she likes you it means I like you is
that Aquafina but the way she was singing I don't
think so but it did sound like her just there I'm
really glad those 98 Degrees of Separation are
behind us just as long as we're together hey you
guys got to try this mudo I love the puns so
great that new song is sick branch I knew you
had an have a closing number yeah thanks what
you didn't think broone was the only band I've
ever been in did you please they you are so in
sync that's in sync this hasn't been in sync the
whole time do we just have an experience where
we thought we were watching in sync the whole
[Laughter] time we've done it again Roxy we had
a misle experience for ourselves twice [Music]
we will Google who everyone is did they do that
to us on purpose I mean they wanted us to think
about N Sync the whole time right but what's this
back story of Branch's band this band he just said
you didn't think you were the only band I know
this in Universe band though better place EXC
see you excit this does sound like insync I was
having a thought of dang all these insync guys
are good voice actors yeah I'm thinking that too
but they they were per purposefully wanting us to
think about I was really thinking they're making
like a commentary on queer representation with
Lance Bass and his earring and like I think they
they want you to think about them executive music
I mean I think Justin Timber like always has
been but I feel like he was way more involved
this time yeah well this was the first time the
story was about him right like where he's the
lead yeah I have a small proposal will you join
the band of course I will I thought you would
never ask you know me too well now get up here
and sing with [Laughter] us this is my dream
life my dream life is amazing feeling
Anna Kendrick's still top bilding
though digs whoa which one was Andrew
what Amy Shimmer you got that right
okay yeah I saw her do something for
it with and sync okay we'll look it
up Camila Cabo that's who that
voice was yep that's that must
be the sister zosa Mammoth what who is she
Christopher mint plaz what did you what's
happening
damn darn dang okay you think there's gonna be a
post credit I there might be do you think so well
I'm kind of hoping for some kind of reconciliation
between Poppy's sister and Dad uh it seems like
they made up pretty fast like forgiveness runs
quick in this franchise some kind of EX if you're
Branch yeah do do you know if this is the last
trolls movie I doubt it I feel like they do like
10 of these oh yeah no the DreamWorks they they
milk their movies for as long as possible okay
so throughout unless you're How to Train Your
Dragon for the whole movie you kept saying that
you liked this better than the second one do you
feel that way right now uh overall yeah I I there
are things I I prefer about the second one I
feel like we have very different experiences
watching this movie Greg you could say that about
literally any movie that ever existed with me and
you that's not true I just feel like sometime the
things that you think are funny are the things
that I think are depressing and the things that
I think are funny are the things that you think
are sad you get you get so caught up in like the
you get very empathe so the naos was good that
was a lot of fun and then I got to drive the van
that was cool so then we got locked in mini golf
of course and there was a giant clown head that
started talking to us this is the reconciliation
you're were hoping for but yeah I'm enjoying the
journey I'm enjoying the journey I'm growing I'm
developing he's in therapy how much I owe
you this is covered by insurance right no
I'm out of network gosh therapist I feel you
I feel you there man before I hear the rest of
your this is also commentary on insurances
and mental health I agree with it's crazy
um but you know everybody's got to get paid wait
everyone be quiet how quick we remember everyone
is wow okay via was camil Crim velvet was Amy
Schumer wow is Andrew reyell who was the one
who played the brother um to Velvet okay that is
a very fascinating oh actual dance choreography so
this was absolutely not in sync for the entire
movie oh yeah no if there's one thing we can
confirm is that we had a very different experience
from everyone else who watched this movie movie
can confirm wrong wrong wrong and wrong we we
just watched orph first kill and the entire
time we were convinced that they shot that movie
two years later and said it was actually 13 years
later we just stop thinking any this entire time
we were like oh wow yeah in this movie the entire
time you think people were shouting at us at home
I I I was like that's obviously Lance Bass Greg
it sounds like him right fo and I just do this
to create engagement in the comments you know
we actually knew the whole time we just we just
wanted you to type away go ahead and troll us and
by the way we deserve to be trolled for this one
if you're listening on Apple or Spotify go ahead
and leave us that five stars don't troll us over
there give us that good comment yeah I remember
I want to see all the nice things they have to
say about us because we banned together we ban
together and we get rated five stars well for
those who are listening we watched trolls band
together and we thought N Sync was the cast
the entire time yeah we did it did happen it
it drastically affected my viewing experience
because the entire time I was going man the
creative control Justin Timberlake must have had
over this one in a while but it still had to be
a commentary on that otherwise they wouldn't
they didn't want us to be thinking like that
they wouldn't have had been five band members oh
yeah no everything he could had three brothers
the commentary making it about branch and Justin
Timberlake and his backstory with being part of
NSYNC like yeah the the entire time they want you
to think about it did you have favorite brother I
mean Floyd yeah easily the best one I like Floyd
too he was good but they're all different and cool
I did kind of miss this being Poppy's story oh of
course sure women's opinion here I needed a male
story yeah it's a good point to identify with yeah
yeah I feel like they should take the franchise in
a male driven Direction I do love sister stuff
though oh I love sibling stuff this story it did
affect me okay go back for a second though so you
were saying about this compared to the first one
second one you talk I want to hear you talk but
you were in the middle of a thought before I can
remember my thought okay I want to hear it um but
I'd rather listen to you why because I want to be
respectful you don't want to troll me no I want to
be respectful wa I just want to know whether you
like this one better or worse than the second one
the first one I would rank this second however I
do think there are things that uh I understand so
one3 two yeah but I in terms of like a a movie um
but I do think the second one undoubtedly gives
you more of what you probably want from a trolls
movie like that one delivers more on the goods
it's more fun it's poppy story and and there
there's a direction about this one that this the
story itself just kind of spoke a little bit more
to me and I do intentionally keep personal life
stuff uh out of videos for for for my reasoning
um but I know in this I said you and I both have
siblings and you went silent yeah well no I love
my siblings uh but we have never mind we have no
siblings we have different we have different um
Dynamics chemistry and Dynamics with with our
siblings and um Back stories with our siblings
and so yeah like there are things for branch that
I'm like I really I really get this like there's
so much about like obviously I don't have like the
same backstory as Bren but there the the emotional
undertones and like the uncomfortability and you
know wanting to be close but feeling like you're
kind of like shelf in you don't really know how
to be yourself like there's so so much about it
that I really identify with and being a younger
sibling too uh so yeah like and I like how it
had like different dynamics of of sibling stuff
where the villains are um you know like you have
an older sister sibling Dynamic but it's it's so
much about like even though you have family it's
also about forming your own identity outside
of your family as well but also knowing how to
be supportive on that path to like I thought
there was actually a lot of cool nuan things
a lot of times there is this like Pixar kind of
does this thing nowadays uh with a lot of their
Disney I hear in general kind of this thing with
their stories of like y don't just live under the
thumb of your parents like there's a lot of that
kind of messaging happening and I get what they're
trying to do and I thought this actually had a
more nuanced version of that in and to a certain
extent by saying don't just live under the thumb
of your sibling uh well there was I mean that was
that clearly for the villains but in terms of
like just the overall Dynamics especially for
the boy band members and branch of yeah you have
to like it's like sunshine in my ear holes that's
a line right there that's what she said um yeah
jez but you don't like sunshine in your it's a
very suggest it's a really weird line um I don't
really like anything in my ear holes no neither
do I uh except when I'm clearing out my ear wax
I got one of those ear wax cameras oh you got
one of those uh yeah because I get like a lot of
yeah I think it's great yeah but are you scared
that you're going to hurt yourself I want to buy
one of those uh no it's actually pretty easy it
is like uncom you get used to it but the when
you first start using it it is like oh my God
am I damaging my ear um I mean I should always go
to a professional but I want to get one of those
yeah they're great they're actually like pretty
affordable my birthday is July 13th yeah sure um
you should treat yourself by buying yourself what
a present for somebody here here uh unprompted I
got you I just noticed something about your uh
whenever we're hanging out your hair's tied up
uh what's up with the trolls your wag we don't
know just who's to say I I totally get what
you're saying though like I love the the Pixar uh
don't get out of your parents you know you can be
your own person thing but I do think that the
trolls movies have had very strong messages for
each movie right and so it is hard for me to rank
them it is really based on sound but like personal
preference and and relation to characters right
because the last one being music is for everyone
don't judge it you know um your thing isn't better
don't be the keeper of things enjoy every you that
kind of the messaging behind that versus this
one which is about the power of siblings and
I do love that Justin Timber that branch and all
of his siblings regardless of the fact that they
were no longer close they had seen each other in
a long time every single one of of the siblings
when they found out that one of them needed their
help they all said yeah let's go and I think that
is the the beautiful message and power family
that it should be hopefully if you do have uh
that family bond where it's like it might not be
your favorite person there might be a lot of past
issues it there might have been things that went
down you might not have talked to somebody in a
while there might be whatever backstory there is
but if somebody needs you that's your sibling and
and that's what I hope for all siblings you know
of course you hope more than that for siblings you
hope that they can be the best and best of friends
and and luckily I have an amazing relationship
with my siblings to be able to experience that but
at the bare minimum I think that what you hope for
for siblings is that when somebody needs you you
come running right and that's what we did see here
and even with the poppy storyline with was it Pia
Mia teia what was what was her sister's name Shia
Z I don't know I felt like it was an I uh don't
remember what it was but with her sibling the hot
one camil Cabo uh the hot can't be calling her
the hot one you're the hot sister aren't you you
know there was that at first poppy asks for her
and she says I can't come with you and that was
out of fear and we see that was the wrong choice
right like you don't want to not go somewhere
out of fear you got to show up for your loved
ones when especially when they're asking and so
then she does make that choice so you're able to
kind of see both sides of it anyway sibling stuff
really gets to me so sounds like you really didn't
like this movie really no I'm just joking you're
speaking with such like a a fervor about the
message and yeah just had a lot of meaning to me
about siblings the whole movie was about siblings
right it was about the sibling Dynamic of the
uh pop stars it was about the sibling Dynamic of
Poppy and her sister I also love that when poppy
got there sometimes we know these movies harp on
like how did we get to this point where a strange
well do are we okay I'm so mad at you if sometimes
instead of wasting time just jump in if you want
a relationship with somebody just eff and jump
into it yeah so I and I did like that we didn't
harp too long on that but just saying that it was
all about siblings about the brothers it was about
the sisters and it was about the pop stars and we
saw very different sibling Dynamics throughout and
what we saw is what works best is when you support
each other yeah it was nice I mean neither I I
appreciate at this movie was trying to take a more
mature Direction I think this the story itself is
stronger the things that were kind of missing for
me were um like when the music was there it's it's
always great like I was I it's a weird at um it's
a weird uh dual feeling I have about the the music
in this movie because when it's there it's like I
was so impressed with how they executed the songs
here I kept out saying out loud like who produced
The Music In this one because this was so well
done um and it felt different like it felt like
the the other ones I don't want to downside cuz
I thought they were great in the other ones too uh
but they they did feel more like yeah the trolls
remix version of them and this felt like I could
just listen I I would put this on and just listen
to it you know you could say the same thing about
the other ones but to me that there was something
that felt more I don't know like a like a a record
produced version of it at I really don't want that
to sound like I'm I'm sliding the other ones the
other ones I get what you're saying cuz I mean I
I can't stop the feeling from the first I listen
to that still like I love I found that through the
movie and I still listen to it um but overall like
this the tunes here were just you haven't heard
that song Until the movie I don't think I might
have heard it before but I don't think I really
listen to it until the movie and and um yeah so
but it's it the music is such a part of the world
and I and weirdly even though it was about getting
the band back together and all that stuff I didn't
feel like I kind of feel like it uh the musical
side of it was not as prevalent as the other ones
were is prevalent prevalent um I think so are are
those two different things that might just be the
pronunciation yeah I'm not sure do you kind of
get what I mean though about what I'm saying not
I don't know I'm not asking you to agree I'm just
saying you get what I'm saying yeah I do I do get
what you're saying it's can't quite pinpoint why
though something for me though was that this movie
was much darker and more upsetting to me so I so
desperately needed the music in this one that I'm
not even judging the quality or the differences
between the last one and this one I just needed
it you know like I was like give me that mash
up because I'm sad right now I guess I just I
didn't succumb to the drama as much as like I I
was really upset the heartfelt stuff I was I got
like Prett I got I got I cried a little bit too
at one point like I got but but it was more when
I'm like touched by something you would get caught
up in the harrowing side of something and I would
be really touched by something whereas you would
be like this is miserable experience with they're
going through and I never quite got there with
the movie whereas you would wait before you go
anywhere you know what's interesting is that the
the uh Lo line of poppy discovers that Branch was
once part of the boy band brozone and it's like
that's interesting or the summary because that's
what IMDb does there the summary right poppy
discovers and they wanted the first thing it's
Poppy's Discovery and it's like this really wasn't
about poppy discovering she is fully relegated to
a supporting character like like let like Viva
that was camil Cabo's name it's not even really
uh ohiv it's easy I said Mia Jesus Christ it's
not even that uh uh uh like Branch was more of
an important supporting character like you could
really there is a version where you could have
done this movie without poppy yeah like I like
her storyline and I like how you got a different
Dynamic again of like the siblings who reunite
who meet each other for the first time and it
is just we just love each other so much I thought
that was so it was so funny to me because um yeah
would Branch you you would expect normally you
would kind of get a bit of like wait who are you
and you kind of go through the drama of that but
I love how it was just a joyous experience and
you don't actually see that a lot in movies yeah
I can't believe that was Eric Andre as John Dory
that's wild that makes sense kid cudy was Clay
which one was Clay you know the one with big
hair that's the thing is like I don't I don't
personally feel like their personalities were
distinct enough I kind of like I I don't know I
got might push back as I me one was obviously more
bossy and then you got Floyd who was like was Kay
the one with the big hair that flowed backwards
or was Clay the one I'm not sure who had the hair
like this or like this okay there's only one who
was a little bit forgettable to me it was the guy
who ran the restaurant with the with the giraffe
wife that the one who you were just naming but
the the one who was with was that clay I might
have been the one was with po Spruce was Bruce
yeah Floyd we know John dor we know yeah Spruce
I thought he was actually a little forgettable
Spruce was Bruce yeah who playso who's Floyd he
was great let's look him up Troy savan yeah you
know him I do I don't know him I have no idea who
this guy is scroll down scroll down trying scrolly
scrolly holy I mean he was in a movie I saw like
13 years ago the idol that's how I know him Idol
the idol you know that big um HBO show that got's
daughter yeah I actually thought she was good in
it nobody else did okay Christopher wait scroll
down Christopher M's PL was all them King gristle
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yep yep yep yep
yep they do good a good job Anderson Pac was in
this too wow a lot of a lot of really cool voices
a lot of great music a lot of good sibling stuff
just to sum it up you would still rank this third
you be honest no no I I might be with you where
it's 132 usually lie on camera you you're known
to be a liar you're a trolly poly oi today huh
you're I I keep saying I'm going to be sweet and
sincerer than I and then you can't I I'm trying
to commit commit to the bit Yeah the bit of being
nice makes it not sincere if you were control
design yourself for a second what's your skin
what's your hair okay my skin would 1,00% be
purple I would be purple my hair would be cornrow
because you don't see any with cornrow color uh
they would be uh green cornrow I'd get a grill I'd
have a tattoo that says damaged on my forehead oh
my God and then I would have a lot of tattoos why
are you the Joker um Joker doesn't have cornrows
and and then I would also damage green hair I
would also have angel wings on my back I get angel
wings could you fly it uh yes I'd be able to spr
Wings and my pants would be those painted pants
that when people go to the gym and they do like
Tik toks be like hey I'm actually wearing pants
at the gym but they're just a spray on pants you
know what I'm talking about no but they're not
actually pants are you kidding no it's a real
thing that people do they like spray the pant like
they spray it to look like they have have pants on
but it's really just like a spray on thing where
is their wee we uh in their underwear usually so
they're wearing underwear with spray paint over
it yeah what the are you making this out no it's a
real thing if I was making it up I I I would sell
that idea and become like really rich why would
you sell that who would buy that that's so weird
influencers by that who influences the influencers
I know right uh what would your what would your
troll look like was that not a perfect transition
for you to talk about our show it's so late in
the video no one's going to care what what was
the what was the what would your troll look like
um have we seen any yellow trolls no maybe yellow
and gold spray paint pants my dude no no spray
paint uh what is it called leggings I literally
saw this one girl she's like an influencer girl
and she went to the gym and then she got kicked
out because she would did a whole it was the
whole thing was obviously set up so she could
get kicked out where like a guy was complaining
being like you're obviously not wearing pants this
is inappropriate and she's like these are pants
and it's like but he knew what they were that it's
like it's a spray on design like it's a real thing
I think we should go go yeah I think we're done no
I'm telling you I think we're good I think I'm
GNA milk I'm gon to bleed your your run time two
hours exactly I think uh you've trolled me enough
yeah I think I I think I do go 132 still I think I
go 132 but I did like two a lot I've liked all of
them I don't know where they go from here I I like
the new character of Viva I would like to explore
their relationship I want to go back to focusing
on puppy puppy I want to know about Poppy's dad
and why he never looked for the daughter those
are my thoughts they do I think the one thing is
that yeah well I'll end with this I I feel like
the movie was at at times at a bit of a I didn't
really like the villains honestly in the movie um
I like the idea of they were really upsetting
I like the concept of the villains but I don't
like that I thought they were kind of like dull
and annoying they were frustrating but not not
in a complimentary way like I like the commentary
they had that was like poking fun at this type of
musician that exists nowadays that becomes famous
via social media I I get it there's no way that
Amy Schumer's singing voice right probably not
like whose voice was that they could have um I
have no idea it's very good um but I do think this
particular one while I would rank it above two I
do feel like at times the storytelling becomes a
also the animation I thought it was Exquisite uh
is a bit at odds where they want to kind of go a
little bit more with the drama like a Pixar movie
or like some of their other DreamWorks films where
that that do take the time to go a little bit more
bold with their Dr drama and characterization but
then they go but we're the trolls franchise so we
got to like uh move past this a little quicker
and uh you know yeah when I felt that they were
actually wanting to to dive in more to that uh uh
emotional stuff so that's the only thing I think
it's possible if I saw two third that I would
like two better I don't know I'm going back and
forth in my head over and over can you put your
leg behind your head right now are you able to I
don't know I am in jeans let's try it I don't
know I'll help you I didn't even I don't know
why my listen th this thing so I was using this
the rolly thing on the ground and at some point
one of your cats went inside so I couldn't roll
and so I my my legs like was hovering them and
then they got we got to get out of here thank you
so much to our favorite trolls no you guys aren't
trolls you're Rejects and that's what makes you
the best so band together leave a comment let us
know what you thought and we'll see you for what
are we doing next let us know what we're doing
next terrifier what is that oh it's a kids movie
about a clown really yeah called terrifier yeah
that's the give away that I've been messing with
you see you for terrifier Troll's [Music] audience